a day after boris johnson said he'd step
down attentions turn to what and who
comes next around the newly cleaned up
palace of westminster the talk is of a
clean break of restoring trust in
government
someone has to grip this moment and make
the right decisions
on friday the first of the political big
beasts announced their standing the
previous chancellor rishi sunak and i
have spent my career bringing people
together sunak's one of two cabinet
members whose resignation led to a
torrent of junior ministers quitting and
johnson eventually giving in
there should be a new leader but on
thursday johnson insisted he'd stay in
post until the new leader was chosen a
process that could take many weeks
within the party initial opposition to
him staying on in the interim seems to
be weakening
i don't think that it would be
appropriate for us whether we're around
the cabinet table or in any other part
of the british government just to kind
of down tools and say actually you know
what we're not going to do anything
until the new boss is in place we have a
duty and our duty is to govern
what's due to happen is all the
conservative members of parliament get
to vote on the leadership candidates it
could take several rounds before they
narrow it down to just two names
assuming neither drops out it's then up
to the wider party membership to pick a
new leader what's different this time is
it's not a difference over policy it's
not parliamentary deadlock as it was
over theresa may with her failure to get
her brexit deal through in this case the
problem is the prime minister and in
particular the prime minister's judgment
his integrity and the fact that he'd
really lost confidence of so many people
in his government and that's meant
that uh that it's slightly weird that
he's continuing the opposition labour
party still say if johnson isn't gone
soon they'll try to force him out using
parliament he shouldn't be desperately
clinging on when he has had to leave
office because of his disgraceful
conduct
and that's why i say
the tory party should remove him
and if they don't we will step up in the
national interest and bring a vote of no
confidence
it's unlikely though that enough
conservative mps would back starma
in two weeks parliament breaks for the
summer leaving westminster to the
tourists and leaving the choice of prime
minister to fewer than 150 000
conservative party members but between
now and then plenty could happen to
change boris johnson's timetable for
leaving downing street nadine barber al
jazeera london